Here are the nine things you must do
when first setting up Cloudbot. First is
lock your project isolation. You must
force every project to have a project
ID. Second is create a master project
and this is your operating system. Next
is write project charters before you do
anything. That's your objective, your
scope in out guard rails and definitions
of success. Next, enforce no project ID,
no work. That is essential to make sure
it doesn't go off the rails. Number
five, install conflict detection so
it'll block if there is conflict
detected. Next, turn those conflicts
into log files in your conflicts folder.
Then pipe those errors directly into
your Messengerbot. I use Slack. Number
eight, define your severity levels up
front. Info, warn, block, reject,
critical. Lastly, kill anything that's
fast but wrong. We don't need that
behavior. We need safety over speed. If
you treat Cloudbot like Chat GPT, it's
going to burn you. If you treat it like
an operating system, it scales.